[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم بينما تستمر
التحضيرات لعقد مؤتمر جناف اثنين الخاص
بسوريا دع وزراء الخارجيه الامريكي
والروسي اطراف الصراع الى الالتزام بوقف
لاطلاق النار يبدا من حلب اضافه الى
اجراءات اخرى لبناء الثقه منها فتح ممرات
انسانيه وتبادل المعتقلين نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقش في
محورين هل تسمح المعطيات الحاليه ميدانيا
بتطبيق المقترح الامريكي الروسي لوقف
اطلاق
النار وكيف سيؤثر نجاح او فشل تنفيذ
الاجراءات التمهيديه المقترحه في مسيره
مؤتمر
جناب
يحتدم القتال في حلب شمالي سوريا مسلحو
الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق والشام يخوضون
حربا داميه ضد بعض فصائل المعارضه هناك
بينما تواصل قوات النظام قصف بعض المناطق
بالبراميل المتفجره في هذه الاجواء يتقدم
وزيرا الخارجيه الامريكي والروسي بمقترح
لوقف اطلاق النار بين القوات الحكوميه
والمعارضه بدءا من حلب ياتي هذا قبل نحو
اسبوع فقط من موعد عقد مؤتمر جنف اثنين
للسلام في
سوريا يبدا العد التنازلي لجنيف اثنين
الذي لن يعقد فيها للمفارق بل في مونتر في
باريس يلتقي كيري ولافروف والابراهيمي
لبحث ما تبقى من تفاصيل الدعوات وجهت
ومعها بروتوكولات الاجتماع فماذا تبقى اذا
بادرات حسن نيه ربما او خطوات اجرائيه على
الارض تمنح الدعوه للاجتماع جدوا لدى
المشككين وطابعا عمليه للمنخرطين في سياقه
من ذلك ما جهر به كيري ولافروف امكان
ترتيب وقف لاطلاق النار بدء من بعض
المناطق تحديدا حلب وهو ما نص عليه بيان
جنيف واحد مقدما وقف اطلاق النار على ما
سواه لكن ما يبدو مقترحا للسلام بوقف
النار بدء من حلب قد يكون فخا سياسيا قبيل
جناف المنطقه تقع شمالي البلاد وعمليا لا
سيطره حقيقيه للنظام عليها بل كانت للجيش
الحر في البدايه لينتهي الامر الى تنظيمات
قاديه اكثر منها سياسيه
كجبهة معادله واضحه قبل جنيف نظام يستطيع
وقف اطلاق النار اذا شاء في مقابل معارضه
سياسيه لا تستطيع ذلك فمن يسيطر على الارض
من قواه او بعضها على الاقل يحارب هذه
المعارضه ايضا امر يجعل مقترح وقف النار
لصالح النظام وروايته عن محاربه ما يسميه
الارهاب وهو ما يعزز مقترحات جرى تداولها
تحت الطاوله منذ شهور حول توحيد جهود
الحكومه السوريه ومعارضيها لمحاربه
الارهاب
ذلك ما يمنح الاسد وقتا اضافيا ان لم يكن
نصرا
تكتيكيا موضوع حلقتنا هذه نناقش مع ضيوفنا
من باريس الدكتور منذر ماخوس سفير
الائتلاف الوطني السوري في فرنسا ومن
بيروت الكاتب الصحفي فيصل عبد الساتر ومن
ريف حلب معنا عبر سكايب توفيق شهاب الدين
قائد كتائب نور الدين الزنكي الاسلاميه
والقياديه في جيش المجاهدين في سوريا نبدا
من حلب والسيد توفيق شهاب الدين ونود ان
نعرف بدايه هل ستقبلون ايه دعوه لوقف
اطلاق النار تبدا من
حلب بدايه السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام
اي يعني نحن نحب ان نعقب على هذا الامر
لماذا لا يجتمع لا لماذا لا يجتمع الوزير
الامريكي والروسي حينما كانت
بالامس تصب امطار من غضب بشار الاسد من
الطيران ومن صواريخ الارض ارض فوق
المدنيين لماذا الان يطرحون هذا الامر
الان لا نستطيع وقف اطلاق النار هذا الامر
امر صعب جدا ومع اننا في هذه الازمه
الحقيقيه الذي نخوضها في الداخل ولكننا
نرى النظام هو في تهشم وفي ضعف نعم صعب
جدا من اي ناحيه اجرائيه ام غير ذلك ام من
ناحيه المبدا لن تقبلوا به لا ليست من
ناحيه
المبدا المبدا لو سمعنا في الامس عندما
كان يقتل الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ وكان
يصب جام غضبه فوق المدنيين لو راينا
من العالم باسره غربا وشرقا لو راينا موقف
واحد مشرف لهذه المساله لكن لكنا نعتقد ان
هذا الطرح سياتي او اتى اليوم في مصلحه
الثوره السوريه او في مصلحه الشعب السوري
ولكن عندما لم نرى منهم موقف بالامس لا
نصدق او لا نيقن اليوم ان هذا الموقف فيه
اي فائده للثوره او الشعب السوري سيد ليس
منه فائده لماذا ان يكون متاخرا احسن من
ان لا يكون البراميل المتفجره لازالت تنزل
على حلب وليس يعني ببعيد ما حدث بالامس
فقط يعني هو اليوم النظام من خلال
اختراقات لتن ظيم
البغدادي احب ان يقول للعالم انني اقاتل
المتطرفين
والارهابيين ان هذه الثوره ليس ليست بثوره
شعب بريء ليست بثوره شعب مظلوم فعندما راى
الصدام
بين المجاهدين والثوار في الداخل عندما
راى هذا الامر
وتهشمت مصلحته من خلال هذا التنظيم يريد
الان ان تطرح هذه المساله او تطرح هذه
المساله ولدينا معلومات الان ان روسيا
تضغط على بعض الدول وطرحتها لدينا في
الساحه بان يقف القتال بين تنظيم البغدادي
والفصائل الذي تقاتل اليوم علما انه
الفصائل الي تقاتل ليس هي من بدات القتال
بل التنظيم هو من بدا القتال هو الذي تجبر
وتكبر وظلم واوقع الظلم على
الابرياء على المواطنين على المجاهدين على
الثوار هو الذي تسلط عليهم حتى انفجر هذا
البركان في وجهه من كل جانب وضح تماما سيد
توفيق نرجو ان تبقى معنا نتحول الى باريس
دكتور منذر ماخوس ونود ان نعرف سيد منذر
دكتور منذر يعني من يملك فعلا
سلطه فرض اي وقف لاطلاق النار ومراقبته في
ذلك وقد سمعنا صوتا على الاقل صوت واحد من
عده اصوات من داخل سوريا رفض
ذلك اعتقد الذين يستطيعون ان يقوموا
بعمليه من هذا النوع هي الفصائل المقاتله
على الارض نفسها لانها هي المعنيه بالدرجه
الاولى والاخيره وكما قال الاخ توفيق اولا
النظام حتى هذه اللحظه لم يقدم ولا حتى لا
اقول وقائع ولا حتى مؤشرات على ان شيئا ما
يمكن ان يحدث على الارض التصعيد الغير
مسبوق الذي حدث في الاسابيع الاخيره منذ
على اقل ولا اقول كل ذلك عندما
بدات حرب اجراميه غير مسبوقه بالقاء
البراميل على حلب واللي امتدت الى كل
المحافظات فقط نعرف في حلب فقط منذ حوالي
اسبوع كان عدد البراميل التي وقت حوالي
100 برميل عدد الضحايا والدمار الذي حدث
يتجاوز بكثير ما حدث حدث في استعمال
الاسلحه الكيميائيه هي حرب اجراميه
بامتياز ضمن هذه الظروف انا اعتقد ليس
هناك من يستطيع ان يتحكم على الارض حتى
المعارضه السياسيه اريد ان اكون شفافا
وزيها وانا ضمن هذه المعارضه لا اعتقد على
انها تملك امكانيه ان تؤثر على الارض
الارض الذي هؤلاء الذين يقاتلون هم يملكون
المفتاح وهؤلاء لا يملكون حتى هذه اللحظه
ولا سبب اولا ان لا يسقوا ان لا يسقوا لا
بالاطراف الدوليه وخاصه حلفاء النظام ولا
بالنظام نفسه ولا بالامكان الواقعيه
لتحقيق وقف اطلاق النار لانه كما تكلم
اخونا منذ قليل هناك اطراف كثيره اليوم لم
تعد
المعادله فلنقل ثنائيه الاطراف اكثر اصبحت
ثلاثيه هناك النظام من جهه هناك الفصائل
المقاتله لكن هذا الا يضعف من موقفكم
اسمحيلي ولو لحظه واحده هناك نعم الا يضعف
من موقف هناك الفصائل المقاتله التي هي هي
انا سوف اتي الى سؤالك هناك الفصائل التي
هي اليوم فلنقل الجبه الاسلاميه هي القوه
الاساسيه اليوم على الارض والجيش السوري
الحر و جبه ثوار سوريا وكتائب المجاهدين
ومجموعه من العسكريين اسم سلطه لديكم على
ؤ كل
هؤلاء لا لا احد يستطيع اليوم ان يفرض على
هؤلاء اي شيء عندما لم يترك النظام اي
فرصه من اجل ان تكون هناك مؤشرات
تسمح بحس النيه نحن نعرف من حيث المبنى
نحن لا نتخ به النظام بالمطلق نحن بعرف ان
هذا النظام مجرم لكن اذا كانت بعض الاطراف
الدوليه تحاول ان تفعل كل شيء من ا ان
يعقد مؤتمر جنيف فمن الواجب وهم بالمناسبه
اقول بصراحه يحاولون نعم لدينا معلومات و
وهذا اليوم فقط حدث اجتماعات مهمه في هذا
الاطار بما في ذلك مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي منذ اقل من ساعه والبارحه مع
السيد وزير الخارجيه هذا المقترح الذي
طرحه الروس
والامريكان اليوم انا اقول ان لم تبذل
جهود خارقه وهم يبدوا بصدد بذل هذه الجهود
هذا ما سمعناه على الاقل
انا لست ايضا متاكد انهم حتى لو بذلوا
انهم سوف يصلون الى نتائج اما من حيث
المبدا فهناك هناك استحاله تماما ان
يتجاهل الناس ما يحدث من مجازر جماعيه على
الارض ومن تدمير شامل ضمن هذه الظروف من
يجر ان يذهب الى مؤتمر جنيف وما هي الفرص
نجاح مثل هذا المؤتمر هم وعيون اعود الى
الاطراف التي ذكرتها هم وعيون لهذه
المساله يريدون ان يبذلوا جهود لكن انا
لست لدي اي ضمانات ان شيئا ما سوف يتحقق
دع نتحول الى بيروت السيد فيصل عبد الساتر
يعني نود ان نعرف باعتقادك سيد فيصل مقترح
كهذا هل يمكن ان يقبل به النظام السوري هو
الذي
يعني لم يقدم ايه
خدمه وكيف يمكن ان يقدم هذه الخدمه لمن
يقصف بالبراميل
المتفجره يعني اولا الموضوع سيدتي الكريمه
ليس موضوع اسداء خدمات الموضوع هو اما ان
تكون هناك عمليه حل شامله على المستوى
السياسي او لا تكون عندما نتعاطى الان مع
الواقع الذي يجري في سوريا ويعني حضره
السيد ضيفكم من باريس تكلم بشكل واضح
عندما كان يدعي الاتئاد انه يمثل الشعب
السوري والثوره السوريه والفصائل المقاتله
وانه يسيطر على 70% من الارض السوريه تبين
انه لا يسيطرون حتى على اعضاء الائتلاف
الذي اصيب
بانتكاسات من حلب الان عبر سكايب اعتقد ان
ال اعتقد ان الامر في مكان اخر والمشغل في
مكان اخر هؤلاء لا يستطيعون ان يحركوا اي
شيء على الارض السوريه الا بامره خارجيه
لبت النظام السوري لو سمحت لي يعني الى اي
مد يمكن الوثوق به بانه ان رغب في ذلك
سيلتزم بايه دهنه هدنه عفوا تجنب
المدنيين الدوله سيده فيروز الدوله تستطيع
ان تحسم قرارها عندما تتخذ قرارا فهي
مسؤوله عنه لانه لا احد يستطيع ان يملي
اوامر على الدوله السوريه حتى لو كان هناك
من يدعي ان الدوله يعني يقدم لها دعم من
بعض الدول والى اخره لكن الدوله دوله يعني
لها سلطتها لها هيبتها لها اداراتها
الهيكليه لا يستطيع اي فريق او اي كاتيبه
ان تخرج عن اطار القرار السياسي للدوله
المركزيه حتى لو ان هذه الدوله اصيبت ببعض
الانتكاسات في امكنه معينه لكنها تبقى
يعني لها القدره في ان تصدر اوامر وتلزم
كل القطاعات العسكريه بان تلتزم بهذه
الاوامر وهذا الامر كان مطروحا في جنيف
واحد والذي افشل موضوع البند الاول يعني
وقف اطلاق النار الذي جاء في جنيف واحد هي
المعارضه المسلحه عندما اعترضت على هذا
الموضوع في حمص واطلقت النار وادعت ان
هناك مجازه حصلت في حمص عف اختراق وقف
اطلاق النار ايضا
سجل في عديد من المرات هدنه العيد في
اكتوبر 2012 في ابريل 2012 من قبل النظام
السوري وحتى الخارجيه الروسيه تحدثت في
هذا الاتجاه
ايضا انا لم اقل ان يعني ال يعني ان الطرف
الاخر هم ملائكه وبالتالي لا تحدث بعض
الخروقات لكن الدوله عندما يحدث خرق معين
يكون هذا الخرق مبررا على اعتبار انها
دوله تمارس سلطه العنف التي تحتكرها بموجب
القانون وهي بالتالي تدافع عن مواقعها وعن
مراكز جيشها لا يمكن ان تعطي التزاما
وان تتعرض لهجوم وان تبقى م الايدي وضح
تما ا اتحول لسيد توفيق شهاب الدين يعني
عندما تقول بانه الوقت قد فات لاي مبادره
بهذا الخصوص نود ان نعرف فعليا تتحدث
نيابه عن من وقد تحدثت انت شخصيا
بان العديد من الفصائل بات موجودا الان
على الارض وان حتى بعض هذه الفصائل باتت
متحاربين يعني بدايه نحن نحب ان نعقب على
كلام
ضيفك عندما يقول هؤلاء لا يستطيعون ان
يتكلمون او يفصلون امرا على الارض لا نعم
عندما يطرح معيار سليم نحن نستطيع نفصل
على الارض ونحن القوى الموجوده على الارض
نحن القوى الذي الان تفصل اي امر كان فيه
مصلحه البلاد والعباد ولكن من الذي يتلقى
الدعم الخارجي والاوامر الخارجيه هذا
النظام الذي نحن نرى من منذ بدايه هذه
الثوره التي اوشكت ان تقترب على ثلاثه
اعوام لا نرى موقف جاد من قبل لا امريكا
ولا روسيا ولا اي دوله حتى الان موقف حازم
عندما ارادوا ان يزيح بعض الرؤساء في ولنا
امثله كثيره من الدول خلال ايام او ساعات
ازحوا هذه الانظمه اما هنا عند بشار الاسد
الذي يخدم نظامه مصالحهم الذي يستعمر
نظامه ويرسل بخيرات بلاده الى هذه الدول
حتى هذه الساعه لم نجد لم نرى موقف واضح
وحاسم من قبل هذه الدول نعم هذا النظام هو
الذي يتلقى الاوامر من
الخارج طبعا نرجو ان تبقى معنا سيد توفيق
وكذا ضيفين الكريم مين الدكتور منذر
والسيد فيصل عبد الساتر نتوجه الان
مشاهدينا الكرام الى فاصل قصير نناقش بعده
تاثير نجاح او فشل تنفيذ الاجراءات
التمهيديه المقترحه على مسيره مؤتمر جناف
ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش امكانيه تطبيق المقترح الامريكي
الروسي لوقف اطلاق النار في حلب قبل مؤتمر
جناف اثنين بشان سوريا نعود لضيوفنا
الكرام تحديدا لباريس الدكتور منذر ماخوس
يعني المعادله ظاهرا على الاقل كما نراها
طرفان نظام سوري قادر ان اراد على تطبيق
اي اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار وفي الطرف
الاخر معارضه تحديدا الائتلاف الوطني
السوري نتحدث عن المعارضه السياسيه غير
قادره وان رغبت بشده في ذلك كيف يؤثر على
الموقف الاجمالي لايه مفاوضات
نعم بالحقيقه يجب انلا تفوت هذه المساله
لان الخطاب الخشب المعلب الحقيقه الذي
يقلب الحقائق ويقول ضيفك من بيروت على ان
النظام السوري لا يتمر بامر احد لان
النظام السوري بالمناسبه هو جزء من عمليه
اقليميه خطيره تهدد الاستقرار والامن في
مجمل المنطقه وليس فقط في سوريا والدول
المجاوره وانما تذهب الى اكثر الى ابعد من
كثير من ذلك
هو يقول انه لا احد ياتمر او لا ياتمر من
الاخرين نعم هو ياتمر نن نعرف ويكفي ويكفي
ان يقف عنه الدعم قليلا ليس فقط الايراني
وانما حتى الروسي لنشاهد اين سو يكون
النظام السوري اليوم الروس للامانه اقول
انا على الاقل شعرت من اتصالات الايام
الاخيره شاعرين بالمسالك يريدون ان يجدوا
ولو مخرج صغير اما هل سيكفي هذا المخرج
هذا موضوع اخر سناتي اليه اما ما يتعلق
بالمعارضه انا قلت ان المعارضه السياسيه
ليس لانها لا
تريد او انها عفوا لا لانها لا تستطيع هي
لا تريد لان دمن المعادله حاليه ودمن تصعد
بربريه النظام لا تريد حتى المعارضه
السياسيه ناهيك عن المعارضه القتاليه على
الارض كيف يتوقف هؤلاء عن القتال والنظام
لا يزال يقوم بعملي التدمير والقتل
البربريه هذا واضح لذلك هذه الرساله في
عنوان ال الراعيين وعلى وجه التحديد عنوان
الروس والامريكيين كما قلت شعروا ولكن لا
ليست لدي شعور اليوم على ان جهودهم سوف
تثمر وهذا هنا اريد ان ادخل الى
سؤالك الشيء الذين يقولونه اليوم هو انهم
يريدون ان يقوموا بعمليه وقف اطلاق النار
بدء من حلب انا اعتقد اليوم تكاد شبه تكون
شبه مستحيله هذا من ناحيه اما ما يتعلق
حول الممرات الانسانيه قال الروس ايضا هم
يتكلمون مع نظام من فتره طويله من اجل
استماع في بعض المناطق لكن نحن تعودنا على
سلم النظام دائما يحاول الالتفاف والدوران
ويعطي شغل امر صغير جدا لا يستحق حتى
الانتباه ضمن هذا هذا هذه المقاربات
بالتاكيد لن يكون هناك اي فرصه لا من اجل
وقف اطلاق النار ولا من اجل الفك الحصار
عن المناطق المحصر هيكي عن التوقف عن
استعمال الاسلحه الثقيله وفي مقدمتها
البراميل وفي وصواريخ سكود والقنابل
العنقوديه والقنابل الفراغيه وكل الاسلحه
الاخرى ليس هناك اي مؤشر بالتاكيد وهمم
هذا بالتاكيد انا اقول لك اليوم لا يناقش
للاسف الناس اساسيات مؤتمر جنيب التي
تتعلق بمضمون جنيف وهو الحكومه الانتقاليه
ذات الصلاحيات الكامله وا بالافق وهو
انتقال الى دوله ديمقراطيه تعدديه دوله
القانون يجل الحديث عليه على الاقل في هذه
الحلقه اليوم اظني دكتور منذر هو هذه
الخطوات الاستباقيه التي يمكن ان تعكس
النوايا اعذرني فقط حتى نوزع الوقت بطريقه
عادله وساعود اليك طبعا بالضبط انا سابقه
سابقه
سابقى مع النقاط الاستباقيه حتى هذه
النقاط الاستباقيه ليست هناك اي مؤشرات
تسمح على ان شيئ سوف يتحقق وبالتالي انا
اضع كل عمليه جنيف محل سؤال كبير سيد فيصل
ما رايك في ذلك هذه النقاط الاستباقيه هل
فعلا يمكن ان تنجح هل يمكن ان تعكس
النوايا الحقيقيه لمختلف الاطراف وان فشلت
فشل المجتمع الدولي ايا كانت الاطراف
المسؤوله عن ذلك في اقرار هذه الخطوات
الاستباقيه الى ماذا يمكن ان يدلل بخصوص
مؤتمر جنا
يعني الذي يتحدث عن هذا الموضوع يعني يدرك
تماما ان موضوع مؤتمر جنيف اثنين اخذ
الكثير من وقت السوريين وربما كلف الكثير
من الدماء السوريه ويعني لو استعرضنا
المواقف السياسيه التي كانت حتى الامس
القريب ترفض الذهاب الى مؤتمر جنيف اثنين
الا بشروط مسبقه واخر هذه الشروط ان لا
مستقبل للرئيس الاسد ولا حضور للرئيس
الاسد كل هذا تخلت عنه كل المعارضه
السوريه وقالت انها تذهب الى جنيف اين دون
اي شروط مسبقه وهذا ما ركز عليه الروسي
والامريكي وما رك غير دقيقه تمام سيد فيصل
اعذرني لان ضيفنا يعني هذا غير صحيح هذا
غير صحيح بالمطلق انا معني بهذا ال
تما ان يكون ب عمليه لن يتنازل احد اسمح
لي والشروط قائمه ولا تمحي اسمحي اسمح لي
ه هذه هذه هذه العنتريات في الاعلام يعني
لقد شاهدنا منها الكثير وتبين ان كل هذا
الموضوع برمته غير موجود الذي صرح بالامس
انه قال ان لدينا اجماعا من الدول عن انه
لا مستقبل للرئيس الاسد ولا
لعائلته في سوريا تبين ان الروسي
والامريكي في مكان اخر اذا كان الائتلاف
وبعض المعارضات الاخرى تظن نفسها انها
منتصره فلتذهب ل وحدها الى جنيف وهي تعرف
تماما ان مؤتمر جنيف اثنين ليس على
امانيهم ولا على اماني بعض الدول مؤتمر
جنيف اثنين هو مؤتمر يبحث الحل العام
للازمه السوريه دون شروط مسبقه وبالتالي
كل فريق ياتي ببعض تصور لمساله هذا الحل
اليوم ركز كيري بشكل واضح ان لا حل عسكري
للازمه في سوريا وان الحل سياسي ايضا
السيد لافروف ر على هذا الموضوع اذا الحل
ليس اذا الحل ليس على طريقه السيد توفيق
شهاب الدين دعني احول هذه النقطه لسيد
توفيق شهاب الدين اسمح لي ان اكمل ان اكمل
النقطه
يعني الموضوع ليست نقاط استباقيه
عندما يطرح السيد كيري والسيد لافروف
اليوم مساله وقف اطلاق النار والممرات
الانسانيه وتبادل المعتقلين هذه مساله هي
ل
اكتشاف النوايا عند الاطراف الموجوده وضح
تما سيد فيصل اعتذر منك لان وقتنا تقريبا
انتهى دقيقه واحده وقد توجهت مباشره لسيد
توفيق شهاب الدين سيد توفيق اذا لا حل
عسكري ومن الواضح على الارض على الاقل كما
يتابع الجميع ان ليس بمقدور احد فعليا
الحسم عسكريا الن تاتي لحظه ربما يراجع
الجميع فيها نفسهم لايجاد حل ما ايا كان
نوعه غير عسكري وضحت الصوره على لسان ضيفك
من بيروت من يعمل بالاجنه الخارجيه نحن لا
ننتظر الحسم من روسيا او امريكا عندما سار
هذا الشعب المظلوم في وجه هذه الطاغيه
الذي لا يزال يعتبر نفسه هو شرعي لسوريا
وتريد ان نقف او او نجلس على طوله الحوار
لا حوار مع هذا النظام لا حوار مع هذا
المجرم ولن يكون هناك حل نحن فيما نرى على
الارض الا عسكريا نحن مستمرين في ثورتنا
في قتالنا ضد هذا النظام ما دمنا نملك اي
قوى ولا يمكن ان يبقى في سوريا الا عندما
يقضي على كل الشعب السوري ها قد قتل مئات
الالاف وهجر الملايين ودمر البنى التحتيه
ولا وحتى هذه الساعه وكانه شيء لم يكن في
سوريا لا نسمع موقف من ممن يدعوا ان هناك
حقوق الحيوان وحقوق الانسان لا نجد لا
حقوق حيوان ولا حقوق انسان يتكلم عن ما
يحصل اليوم في ش الشعب السوري ولا يزال
ضيفك هذا يعتبر ان الاسد يمتلك الشرعيه من
اجل ان يبقى وان يكون هناك حوار لوقف
اطلاق نار او جنيف او ما شبه ذلك لا ننتظر
من احد شيء الذي لم يستطع حتى تاريخ هذه
اللحظه ان يكون له موقف مشرف في التاريخ
او عبر حقوق الانسان لن ننتظر منه اليوم
شيء ابدا اشكرك جزيل الشكر توفيق شهاب
الدين قائد كتائب نور الدين الزنكي
الاسلاميه والقيا ملاحظه
اخيره ملاحظه اخيره ست في ملاحظه اخيره
نعم الشرعيه من يقرره من يقررها الشعب
السوري اذا كنت فعلا منظرا للديمقراطيه
كما تدعي اذهب الى استفتاء بعد عمليه
سياسيه ل الاستفتاء يكون بعدما تتوقف
البراميل المتفجره اشكر جزيل الشكر السيد
فيصل عبد الساتر الكاتب الصحفي كنت معنا
من بيروت اعتذر منك لان وقتنا انتهت دكتور
منذر ماخوس الاتلاف الوطني السوري في
فرنسا شكرا جزيلا لكل ضيوفنا الكرام الوقت
انتهى تماما نشكركم جزيل الشكر دمتم في
رعايه الله والسلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم